[Music]
when betty returns she gives the
operator the number on her receipt
and deposits the proper amount in the
coin slot the operator again
opens the locker by remote control
and there's the garment cleaned and
pressed
america's love affair with vending
machines goes back generations even
before
that 1940s advertisement today
there are about seven million vending
machines in the united states
serving us sodas snacks and sundries to
the tune of nearly 22 billion dollars a
year or
quick math 62 dollars a person but for
sheer mind-numbing variety and volume
japan is hands down the vending machine
capital of the world
lucy kraft dug out some spare change for
this story
it's hard to overstate japan's total
infatuation with the vending machine
the country has so many there's one for
every 30 people
the blinking lights and friendly glow
seem to beckon from
every milk and cranny banks of vending
machines line busy walkways
super slim versions sprout from lonely
corners
making it nearly impossible to escape
the pause that refreshes
a low crime rate and a craving for
convenience
have made japan a mecca for automated
self-service
junk food is actually harder to find
than options like
fresh bananas or artisanal soup broth
that's a whole grilled fish right inside
the bottle
so you've got the munchies if you're in
japan you're in luck
there's a wide variety of treats to
choose from like rhino beetles
scorpions grasshoppers and giant water
bugs
all full of protein and gluten free
so i went for the chocolate covered
super worms
that's nasty at tokyo's haneda airport
the price of a green tea
also buys a tea serving sprite
a coffee machine that produces latte
foam art
planner musashi sakura i said there are
a lot of opinions about this but
japanese are basically shy vending
machines are perfect for
introverts there's a tyranny of choice
from plush toys to wood crafting kits
to collectibles like trading cards pop
star posters
and cat sushi trinkets
at this buddhist temple good luck
amulets
sold as discreetly as sodas even higher
end products get the vending machine
treatment
like tiffany perfume and freshwater
pearls
vending machines are now high art this
image by photographer aj ohashi
auctioned in london for more than forty
thousand dollars
shining there in the snow the vending
machine seemed
human to me he said ohashi has amassed 1
000 more photos
after 13 years spent capturing the
vending machine in the wild
he said he's only begun to scratch the
surface
for cbs this morning saturday lucy craft
tokyo that is a great image lucy
thank you for eating the worm i wouldn't
have done it
but thank you she said next delivery not
happening what is it
it's fedexing its way in so next weekend
grasshoppers
worms and super butt was a super water
bug what is the strangest thing you've
ever tasted
uh i was at a chinese market during the
olympics
uh what 12 years ago or so odd fried
um items items good i enjoyed it
scorpion you can cover it up good stuff